(INDISTINCT BAR CHATTER)
I saw Lawrence
and his new girlfriend
-the other day.
-Yeah. What'd you do?
I said hello, uh,
got my shit to go,
and keep it pushing.
He looked really happy.
So... you good?
'Cause that would
have activated me, I'm petty.
I mean...
I'd by lying if I said it
didn't bother me a little bit.
We were together for five years.
Dee, you ain't been broken up
that long.
I know.
But the person he is now
is not the person
-he was with me.
-What do you mean?
Like they were out to lunch,
and I'm pretty sure
he was gonna pay.
(CHUCKLES) I never got that.
That's true, niggas don't
be paying.
(CHUCKLES) Yeah, it--
Oh no, I got the nigga
with potential.
You know, I got the work
in progress.
And it took a lot of support
and patience and-- I just--
I feel like she's reaping
all the benefits
of his time with me.
(SIGHS) Damn.
Let me shut up,
'cause I know I don't have
-the right to feel like that.
-No, you have the right
to feel however you wanna feel.
Seriously.
-Fuck that nigga.
-(CHUCKLES SOFTLY)